but were your parents supportive did did
they try to
get you away from acting or did you have
the bug because you were around them and
you knew so much about plays and
and did they kind of just say all right
this is what you want to do
i think my parents were just happy that
i was
doing something um there was not
i i left school at 14 and i was uh
what do you mean you left school at 14
who just says i'm leaving school at four
i just refused to go i just stopped
going
you know and and basically said to my
mom like are you gonna call the truant
officer and send me to jail
and i and she wasn't prepared to do that
and i just
wasn't i just no longer went um
and had some some arrests and um
you were arrested yeah i yeah
i was how old in the 80s in the late 80s
very young um
i was a pain in the ass and so
you know i had a friend who who was an
actor
and he had seen me in a play at school
when i was like 14 right at the end and
he's
and he was aware that i was doing
nothing and left school
and said to me like you should come to
my acting class you should just do that
like this guy needs something to do and
where is this where is this
all in la all in la so you went to this
acting class
went to this acting class for a year
from 16 to 17
kind of got frustrated with the acting
class
uh and then was like i'm gonna go
and and you know there were levels there
was like the the beginner's class
right and then there was the
intermediate my friend was in the
advanced class so i always was like
i gotta get to the advanced class with
my buddy that'll be fun never got past
the beginner class
and quit and just started working you
know like
taking uh what was the magazine
backstage
and sending agents my picture and then
the agent's like
you look interesting i'll send you out
on an audition we'll see what happens
what first that's rare my first day of
auditions
i had melrose place and boy meets world
i went to melrose plate no i went to boy
meets world first
then driving to melrose place i was told
i had a call back for boy meets world
after melrose place go to melrose place
get a call that i got the job but then
they're discussing it and they're like
oh he's not
in sag we're not hot we're not gonna
hire him go
back to boy meets world and get boy
means world which i did for three years
that was day one of auditioning